be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly what's going on guys this is
Rob and welcome back to Marvel requests
Monday it's been a long time since we
made one of these videos but for those
of you new guys Marvel requests Monday
is a weekly series where I hand over the
reins of my youtube channel to you guys
and let you guys decide what character
team or concept I'll do a discussion on
related to Marvel Comics this week we're
focusing on the relationship between
mistress death Thanos and Deadpool
so the relationship between deadpool and
mistress death and Thanos is really kind
of interesting here what we're going to
do with this video is we're gonna split
it in half basically we're gonna have
the first portion talking about Deadpool
and then we're gonna have the second
portion talking about Thanos and what
we're gonna find is this really
interesting concept where we see that
with Joe Kelly's run on Deadpool
the relationship between Deadpool and
death is relatively comedic but when we
get to that us and we talk about Jason
Aaron Jason Aryan Thanos rising and so
on and so forth we're gonna find the
relationship is actually much darker and
it's very sinister but with Joe Kelly's
run on Deadpool what we do is we
actually jump to to Deadpool 1998 with
the whole mistress death and Deadpool
event and what this does is it really
kind of gives us I guess an origin of
source to the idea of Deadpool that is
to say when he first became dead but
when he gained his healing factor and so
on and when he was being experimented on
by the government one of the things that
kept him going was the promise of being
able to be with mistress death in fact
she had basically told him here that if
he had effectively given up when he went
through this process when the time came
when he died if he had surrendered
himself he would have had her but over
the course of these experiments before
it is that he actually I guess goes to
the process of dying he and mistress
death have this very I don't know I
guess very physical relationship with
one another were they're very intimate
with each other's the best way I know
how to describe it without getting too
in-depth but for the most part these are
basically just a series of events that
characterized mistress death as being
more human in nature as being less
sinister is what we had seen with her
appearance of various than of stories
and so on but of course what we had seen
is that by the end of this entire thing
that that mistress death who had
basically confessed that she would fall
in love with with a Deadpool the
Deadpool could be with her forever was
ready to embrace him when the time came
when he was about to die but the problem
was his healing factor kicked in and so
as a result he was not able to marry
mistress death he was not able to be
with mistress death for eternity now
this entire story actually keeps on it
continues on and in Deadpool vol 1 I
believe in joke during Joe Kelly's run
with issues number a 61 through 64
what this was was called the funeral for
a freak storyline and what this did was
give us the events including a I guess
the arch-nemesis as we consider it of
Deadpool a villain named T ray who
ultimately cursed Deadpool with life now
this is kind of a misnomer here a lot of
people believe that it was Thanos who
had cursed Deadpool with life and Thanos
did to a degree but he did it through
tear a tear a who of course was
previously I guess a mercenary that
competed with Deadpool for four
contracts and things like that but was
ultimately the byproduct of Deadpool
having killed T Ray's family for reasons
that we'll get into another time the
result here is that the TV had involved
himself in different kinds of mysticism
different kinds of supernatural arts and
so during the funeral for free story
when Deadpool was presumed to be dead
and was actually getting ready to join
mistress death that his his hand which
was still still there began to sprout
the rest of his body and as a result he
ended up living on and that's how we
really gained the idea that deadpool can
grow from a single hand because this is
where it happened is in this story now
over the course of a funeral for a freak
Deadpool copes with the fact that he's
basically going to be living forever of
course he confronts and learns the TA
was the one that did this to him but at
the very end of the story in issue
number 64 we find that it was Thanos who
had cursed him now again
Thanos had cursed Deadpool with life by
virtue of T ray because in Thanos's mind
Stannis was in love with mistress death
and mistress death was the only person I
guess Thanos was the only person that
mistress death should be within the eyes
of Thanos and so because mistress death
had proclaimed her love for Deadpool
Thanos effectively cursed him said he
could never die and so that he would be
in love or I guess mister stuff would
never be able to be with him as long as
he isn't in existence I guess for all
eternity now this doesn't necessarily
mean that that pool can't just simply be
wiped from the face of existence by
somebody you know like Galactus or
something like that but for the purpose
of anybody killing him in any
conventional means it simply means that
he and mistress death will never be
together again now we don't really know
at least I'm not really sure what kind
of ramifications this has in relation to
mistress deaths perception of Thanos
what we're going to do here is we're
going to transition over to Thanos we're
gonna transition over to the story of
mistress death and Thanos and we're
gonna find here is that this is a very
long
relationship with it's between the two
of them but it's a very dark and a very
sinister relationship here the so where
the relationship between deadpool and
mistress death was more comedic where it
was more kind of this parity of the idea
of mistress death and more in depth in
the realm of them having a physical and
very heated relationship the
relationship between mistress death and
Thanos is much much darker and in fact
what we're going to be doing here is
we're gonna be citing Jason's and Jason
Aaron's
Thanos rising which pretty much gives us
the origin of Thanos and I in Marvel
Comics the reason why is because what
we're gonna find is that mistress death
actually meets Thanos when he's a child
and indeed this is what we see of course
once the analyst was already born he's
depicted as being kind of a strange and
his mother really believes that he's
gonna grow into be some kind of a
monster and so with an attempt to kill
him she fails and is ultimately housed
in an insane asylum and Thanos says he
grows as he gets older of course makes
friends with various classmates them
whatnot but this is when mistress death
visits him for the first time now she
visits him and relates to him as a child
and what she does is basically go to him
really kind of trick him into believing
that because he's different that
ultimately he'll never be accepted by
that group but what we also find is that
she uses a little tactic she uses little
things to to ultimately steer him on
this course to become an evil person for
example one of the things that happens
here when he's a child is that he takes
several of his classmates of his friends
into a cave which is housed by these
relatively large lizards which dot the
landscape of the moon of Titan and what
happens here is that there's some kind
of a cave-in and so once that is able to
weld it I guess actually dig himself out
here he finds the rest of his classmates
but they've been eaten alive or they had
been consumed by all these different
lizards so once the analyst gets back
once he makes it back to the surface
he's considered to be the one who had
actually done this people believe that
he's the one that had murdered these
people murder these children so again
mistress death uses this as a way to
kind of feed on this growing perception
of Thanos now again she doesn't really
tell us why it is that she does this at
least not yet we're somewhat just kind
of given this idea that he's ultimately
beginning to form this relationship and
so what happens
with the coaxing of mistress death danos
who was seeking to find out why he is
the way he is why he looks different
what it is about him that gave him his
genetic mutation begins to go about this
process of dissecting and experimenting
on various things but at the same time
he also begins to take a more sinister
Road a really good example here is that
in response to these lizards having
eaten his friends after the goading of
mistress death each travels back to the
cave and then kills them all but what he
also does is take some of these lizards
and experiment on them that is to say he
died such them and analyzes them after
these lizards he moves on to these I
guess cave trolls would be the best way
to describe there were cave Apes and
again he's really kind of dissecting
them at the entire time he's talking to
her about what it is that he's doing
he's explaining what it is that he's
doing what he's trying to find here and
ultimately as things progress he begins
moving into the realm of other Titans
actually killing other people from the
realm of tightener for the moon of Titan
in an attempt to understand the genetic
makeup of I guess people and of
different materials within the realm of
Titan to understand why it is that he's
coming to be the way he is now all this
really begins to come to a head
once Thanos becomes an adult after he
leaves Titan and what he does is again
he begins going about the cosmos of
course he has several children he is
with several women and for the most part
it seems as though he's left this woman
mistress death behind on Titan so at
this point he's just kind of by himself
but again as time progresses what Jason
Aaron really tells us here is that
regardless of the women that Thanos had
fallen in love with regardless of the
woman that he had had children with it
ultimately none of them were mistress
death and so this really begins to take
shape and form and explain to us why
he's so obsessed with the idea of
mistress death now eventually the time
comes after he had conquered various
ships or I guess I conquered a
particular brat hired ship taken over as
captain as well as formed some sort of
armonica that he returns back to Titan
and when he does he actually meets
mistress death again and what mistress
death does has continued to go to him
but at this point in time Thanos is
being more mature is pursuing her as a
romantic interest now as opposed to when
they were younger and so what she says
is that she'll give herself over to
Thanos but only once he has no more
wives and no more bastard children and
so what he does is actually go back into
the car
and kill every single child and every
single life that he had now of course we
know he's not successful in killing them
all which was the entire basis for the
Infiniti event when Thanos came back to
the planet Earth it was looking for his
for his bastard son but what we do know
is that as far as we know in this
circumstance Thanos has killed pretty
much everybody and so again speaking
with mistress death misters death
continues to really kind of go to him
here and really kind of continue on and
to say that all he has to do is do one
more thing if it's just one more thing
she'll give herself over to him and
that's how it always works with a
relationship between mistress death and
Thanos as long as there's one more thing
then he'll go through with it but what's
also really funny here is that once he
actually takes back off into space
mistress death presumably follows him
but the problem is that no one else can
see mistress death and so as far as the
other members of his crew are concerned
they see him either taking corpses into
the into his private quarters and then
crying because they won't embrace him or
else talking to someone and no one else
can see and so of course they consider
him to be quite insane here and in the
face of this revelation when Thanos asks
who this woman is what she does is
revealed herself to in fact be mistress
death now what Jason Aaron establishes
here is a Thanos didn't know this before
Thanos didn't know this woman was
mistress death everything he had been
doing up to this point had been the
coaxing of a random woman a woman he had
fallen in love with but couldn't let go
of and while she tells Thanos is that by
virtue of his actions by virtue of what
it is that he's done up to this point
that everything that he's live for
basically means that death is the only
person that could ever truly love Thanos
that no normal mortal being were even
immortal being that has any measure of
compassion could ever really fall in
love with Thanos and what we would
expect here is a Thanos would walk away
but instead he doesn't but again this
really just kind of ties into the idea
of Thanos said his in his obsession his
affection for mistress death is because
in the end there really isn't any one he
feels that he can love besides her
because he's killed so many people
because he is so immersed and the
concept of death it seems as though
mistress death is truly the only person
he could love
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead bring this video between and I
hope you guys enjoyed it and now be sure
to submit your request for next week's
model request Monday and yeah so I will
catch you guys later peace